I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi there. We are really excited because today on Office Lady 6.0,
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正为你们带来终极的《办公室》粉丝播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事，深入探索《办公室》的世界。我们是《办公室女士 6.0》。大家好。我们非常兴奋，因为今天在《办公室女士 6.0》节目中，
we got to speak with actress and podcaster Christine Taylor. What an absolute delight. I love her. We want to be besties. We're going to try not to stalk her. Yeah. All right. So you guys might know Christine from her time on the Nickelodeon 90s teen comedy,
我们有幸采访了演员兼播客主持人克里斯汀·泰勒。她真是太令人愉快了。我爱她。我们想成为闺蜜。我们会尽量不去跟踪她。好的。那么，你们可能从克里斯汀在尼克儿童频道 90 年代青少年喜剧中的表现认识她，
Hey Dude, our very own Matt Beagle. Very much knows her from that. Very much knows her from that. You'll hear it. Or you might know her from her role as Marcia Brady in the Brady Bunch movies. She's phenomenal. Mm-hmm.
《嘿，老兄》，我们自己的马特·比格尔非常了解她。非常了解她。你们会听到的。或者你们可能从她在《布雷迪家族》电影中饰演的玛莎·布雷迪一角认识她。她非常出色。嗯。
She has also starred in a number of other comedies like The Wedding Singer, Dodge Ball, Zoolander, and now she is the host of a new 90s-inspired podcast, Hey Dude, The 90s Called. We had such a great time talking with her about all of this and also her love of the office, you guys. Her and her family have watched The Office. That was really fun to hear about. Well, listen, let's get to it. Hello, Christine.
她还主演了许多其他喜剧，如《婚礼歌手》、《躲避球》、《超级名模》，现在她是 90 年代风格新播客《嘿，老兄，90 年代来电了》的主持人。我们和她聊这些以及她对《办公室》的热爱时非常开心，伙计们。她和她的家人都看过《办公室》。听到这些真的很有趣。好吧，听着，让我们开始吧。你好，克里斯汀。
Welcome to Office Ladies. Hi, ladies. This is so fun. First of all, I'm so honored. I was like, I can't believe they're asking me to be on because I'm just such big fans of yours. I mean, obviously a fan of the office, but both of you, Jenna, I've gotten to meet you a few times and saw you recently, but Angela, I've never met you. And I just feel like I'm such fans of both of you. But I was like, I don't have any ties to the office.
欢迎来到《办公室女士》。你们好，女士们。这太有趣了。首先，我感到非常荣幸。我当时想，我简直不敢相信她们邀请我来，因为我真的是你们的超级粉丝。我的意思是，显然我是《办公室》的粉丝，但你们两位，珍娜，我见过你几次，最近也见过你，但安吉拉，我从未见过你。我真的觉得我是你们两位的超级粉丝。但我当时想，我和《办公室》没有任何联系。
I mean, other than I watched it and I love it. But yeah, so I was like, I'm never going to say no to spending an hour chatting with you girls. Well, listen, this is Office Lady 6.0 and we get to talk to people we think are freaking fantastic. And you are one of those people. We're so thrilled to have you on today. Yes. Thanks. But before we dive in to our interview, we're so excited you're going to join us for our chit-chat question of the week. Oh, I'm so excited. This comes from Judy W. in San Jose, California, who says, Hi, ladies, I met Angela at the Fan Expo Convention in San Francisco last year, and she gave me an office ladies lunchbox.
我的意思是，除了我看过它并且我很喜欢它。但是的，所以我当时想，我永远不会拒绝和你们这些女孩聊天一小时。好吧，听着，这是《办公室女士 6.0》，我们有机会和我们认为非常棒的人交谈。而你就是其中之一。我们今天非常高兴你能来。是的。谢谢。但在我们开始采访之前，我们非常兴奋你能加入我们的每周闲聊环节。哦，我太兴奋了。这个问题来自加利福尼亚州圣何塞的朱迪·W，她说，嗨，女士们，去年我在旧金山的粉丝博览会上见到了安吉拉，她给了我一个《办公室女士》的午餐盒。
I absolutely love it. I have it on my shelf in my office. It got me thinking back to my grade school days and how I would get to pick a new lunchbox each year for school. My favorite was the year I got a Wonder Woman lunchbox. So I'm curious, what lunchbox did you have as a kid? Aw, this makes me so happy. Christine, just for your information, I somehow ended up with a whole bunch of our merch delivered to my house.
我非常喜欢它。我把它放在办公室的架子上。这让我想起了我的小学时代，以及我每年是如何为学校挑选一个新的午餐盒的。我最喜欢的是我得到神奇女侠午餐盒的那一年。所以我很好奇，你小时候用的是什么午餐盒？噢，这让我太开心了。克里斯汀，顺便告诉你，我不知怎么地收到了一大堆送到我家的周边商品。
And my husband's like, babe, what are we doing with all these lunchboxes? So I brought a bunch of them and handed them out to people as I met everyone. So Judy, I'm so glad you liked it. Yeah, we should say our lunchbox is no longer available for purchase. And Angela, you got these. overflowed. I just said, you can deliver it at my house. And I want you guys to know a truck showed up that was like the biggest thing I've ever seen. It had like a crane that was like, beep, beep. Wait, where did you store them all? Exactly, Christine. They're coming out of our ears,
我丈夫说，宝贝，我们要怎么处理这些午餐盒？所以我带了一大堆，在我见到大家时分发给了他们。所以朱迪，我很高兴你喜欢它。是的，我们应该说我们的午餐盒已经不再出售了。安吉拉，你收到了这些。溢出来了。我只是说，你可以送到我家。我想让你们知道，一辆卡车出现了，那是我见过最大的东西。它有一个起重机，发出哔哔声。等等，你把它们都存放在哪里了？正是如此，克里斯汀。它们多得都要溢出来了，
which is why my husband and I caravan to San Francisco with the back end of an SUV full of them. But they're so cute. And chances are if you meet me at a convention, you're going to get one. Oh, that's so great. I mean, our podcast is a 90s podcast, so it is so nostalgic and it's very retro. So we talk about a lot of these things on our podcast, but I have to say, like, I am so cliche. Like I had a Brady Bunch tin lunchbox. Did you really? Stop it. Like an original from the Brady Bunch because that was like my favorite growing up. And I think I might have also had a Charlie's Angels lunchbox. Is that? Oh, that's a classic. It's like definitely click. for me. So those were two important ones for me. What about you guys? Well, I just remember what Judy is saying about every year as part of back-to-school shopping going down the aisle and looking at all the lunch boxes and just painstakingly, it felt like such a big decision. Like what am I going to represent with my lunch each day for this year? And I think my first,
这就是为什么我和我丈夫开着一辆装满午餐盒的 SUV 去了旧金山。但它们太可爱了。如果你在大会上见到我，你很可能会得到一个。哦，那太棒了。我的意思是，我们的播客是一个 90 年代的播客，所以它非常怀旧，而且非常复古。所以我们在播客中谈论了很多这些事情，但我必须说，我真的很老套。我有一个《布雷迪家族》的铁皮午餐盒。你真的有吗？别说了。就像《布雷迪家族》的原版，因为那是我成长过程中最喜欢的。我想我可能还有一个《查理的天使》午餐盒。是吗？哦，那是经典。对我来说绝对是点击。所以那两个对我来说很重要。你们呢？好吧，我只是记得朱迪说的，每年作为返校购物的一部分，走在过道里看着所有的午餐盒，费尽心思地挑选，感觉这是一个很大的决定。就像今年我每天要用我的午餐代表什么？我想我的第一个，
My first lunchbox, the one that I really remember, was strawberry shortcake. Oh, yes. Yes, I had a strawberry shortcake. Strawberry shortcake with all my heart. She smelled so good. She was so cute. And all the different shades of pink. Yeah.
我的第一个午餐盒，我真正记得的那个，是草莓甜心。哦，是的。是的，我有一个草莓甜心。全心全意地爱着草莓甜心。她闻起来太香了。她太可爱了。还有各种深浅不一的粉红色。是的。
So pretty. Yes, but then there was also blueberry muffin who I also thought smelled great. And then there was that one that was like an apricot, right? Wasn't there someone who was an apricot? I don't know. But the thing that came into my head when I heard this question was my strawberry shortcake lunchbox. I had, wait for it, this is going to make me sound like such an old lady. I had Holly Hobby.
太漂亮了。是的，但还有一个蓝莓松饼，我也觉得闻起来很棒。然后还有一个是杏子味的，对吧？有没有人是杏子味的？我不知道。但当我听到这个问题时，脑海中浮现的就是我的草莓甜心午餐盒。我曾经，等等，这会让我听起来像个老太太。我曾经有霍莉·霍比。
Oh, Holly Hobby Hobby Hobby. Do you remember Holly Hobby Hobby? Holly Hobby is coming to mine too. Oh, my gosh. That was my very first lunch box, and I was so tickled by it. And then I think I had one that was the Muppets. I had like a Muppets lunchbox. already in the comedy, already into it.
哦，霍莉·霍比。你还记得霍莉·霍比吗？霍莉·霍比也出现在我的脑海里了。哦，天哪。那是我的第一个午餐盒，我对此感到非常高兴。然后我想我有一个《布偶秀》的。我有一个《布偶秀》的午餐盒。已经在喜剧里了，已经沉浸其中了。
Already got it. I know. You've already got it. I'm just an old lady who likes to laugh. But you know what's funny? Speaking of Holly Hobby, I have a paint by number that my dad made me from when I was really little. And it's a Holly Hobby paint by number that we found it somewhere in storage. And I have it just like with a bunch of pictures and things that I have. on a little desk, but I have it kind of pushed in the back. So I see Holly Hobby almost every day of my life. And I love that you are into Holly Hobby, too. Well, since we're talking about old toys, did either of you have my friend Mandy or my friend Jenny? No. Did you have one of us? Did you have one of us? No. They came in like a case, like an old-timey steamer trunk that you might have to put on the Titanic to make a long voyage. And the friend, either Mandy or Jenny, the doll, was in one side of the trunk. And then
已经得到了。我知道。你已经得到了。我只是一个喜欢笑的老太太。但你知道什么很有趣吗？说到霍莉·霍比，我有一个我爸爸在我很小的时候为我做的数字油画。那是一个霍莉·霍比的数字油画，我们在仓库里找到了它。我把它和一堆照片和东西放在一起。在一个小桌子上，但我把它推到了后面。所以我几乎每天都能看到霍莉·霍比。我很高兴你也喜欢霍莉·霍比。好吧，既然我们在谈论旧玩具，你们两个有“我的朋友曼迪”或“我的朋友珍妮”吗？没有。你们有我们其中的一个吗？没有。它们装在一个盒子里，就像一个老式的蒸汽行李箱，你可能得把它放在泰坦尼克号上进行长途航行。那个朋友，曼迪或珍妮，那个娃娃，在行李箱的一边。然后
her closet of clothes was like the other side of the trunk. And she came with one change of clothes and little shoes. Does she have like little hangers? Like little hangers for her clothes? Oh my gosh. Little hangers. I still have it. What was the scale? Like how big was she? She was about the size of an American girl doll. Well, it sounds. like a precursor to an American girl. Tell us what I was going to say. It kind of was. Yeah, I think it was. But this predates the Cabbage Patch Kid. That was the craze. Yes, the Cabbage Patch Kid 80s. I feel like it was. And I was like obsessed with my Cabbage Patch Kid. Oh, yeah. Whose name was Christine. Oh. What? Yeah, Christine Marie and Casey Alexander.
她的衣服衣橱在行李箱的另一边。她带着一套换洗衣服和一双小鞋子。她有小衣架吗？就像给她衣服用的小衣架？哦，天哪。小衣架。我还有它。比例是多少？她有多大？她大约有美国女孩娃娃那么大。好吧，听起来像是美国女孩的前身。告诉我我想说什么。它确实有点像。是的，我想是的。但这比卷心菜娃娃还要早。那是当时的狂热。是的，80 年代的卷心菜娃娃。我觉得是这样。我当时对我的卷心菜娃娃着迷。哦，是的。她的名字叫克里斯汀。哦。什么？是的，克里斯汀·玛丽和凯西·亚历山大。
were my two cabbage patched children. I loved them. Beautiful girls. Well, Judy, thank you so much for that question. I think we had a lot to say about our lunch boxes. And why don't we take a quick break? And when we come back, Christine, we heard you're a real big fan of the office, so we can't wait to ask you about that.
是我两个卷心菜娃娃孩子。我爱她们。漂亮的女孩。好吧，朱迪，非常感谢你的提问。我想我们对午餐盒有很多话要说。我们为什么不休息一下呢？当我们回来时，克里斯汀，我们听说你是《办公室》的超级粉丝，所以我们迫不及待地想问你关于那个的问题。
But also, you and I have three things in common that are kind of fun. Ooh. Dun, dun, done. That's a good cliffhanger. All right, we're back. Christine, are you ready to hear what you and I have in common? I cannot wait. This was really fun for me to find out. Well, first of all, we both love tennis. And we were both at Wimbledon this year, not on the same day. But we both had tickets to center court. But you, am I correct? You were in the royal box. Is that right? We did get ourselves into the royal box. Yes.
而且，你和我还有三件共同点，挺有趣的。噢。咚，咚，咚。那是个很好的悬念。好了，我们回来了。克里斯汀，你准备好听听你和我有什么共同点了吗？我迫不及待了。这对我来说真的很有趣。好吧，首先，我们都喜欢网球。我们今年都在温布尔登，虽然不是同一天。但我们都有中央球场的门票。但你，我没说错吧？你在皇家包厢。是这样吗？我们确实进入了皇家包厢。是的。
Oh, my gosh. I take no responsibility. That's a person. perk of my husband. Yes. Oh my gosh. It's so special, the tennis experience, don't you think? Yes. I've been to the three of the four grand slams. Wow. I have not been to the Australian Open, but diehard tennis fan. Like grew up watching it. I played a little, I played okay. I was never great. I played in my high school tennis team. Mediocre. But the watching it. And from a really young age, but we belonged to like a tennis swim club growing up. I grew up in Pennsylvania and they'd do a trip to the U.S. Open, nosebleed seats, but like we would all bus in and everyone would just scatter and then meet back at like 10 o'clock at night. And so my
哦，天哪。我不承担任何责任。那是人脉。我丈夫的福利。是的。哦，天哪。网球体验太特别了，你不觉得吗？是的。我去过四个大满贯中的三个。哇。我没去过澳大利亚网球公开赛，但我是一个铁杆网球迷。从小看着它长大。我打了一点，我打得还可以。我从来都不算好。我在高中的网球队打球。平庸。但观看它。从很小的时候就开始了，但我们成长过程中属于一个网球游泳俱乐部。我在宾夕法尼亚州长大，他们会组织去美国网球公开赛的旅行，虽然是山顶座位，但我们都会坐大巴去，然后每个人都会散开，晚上 10 点再集合。所以我的
memories of those years were the early 80s of like McEnroe and Becker. I mean, so many of the big sort of icons were playing still back then. And I just fell in love with it. Steffie Graff and Kim Kleisters. Oh, my God. I know. All of them. Okay, so that's one thing. Okay, that's tennis.
对那些年的记忆是 80 年代初的麦肯罗和贝克尔。我的意思是，当时很多大偶像还在打球。我只是爱上了它。斯特菲·格拉芙和金·克里斯特尔斯。哦，天哪。我知道。她们所有人。好吧，这是一件事。好吧，那是网球。
And then my second thing, and this is the thing that just completely floored my family. So you're in many movies that are my family's favorites. All my kids are so tickled that I'm meeting you today. But as we were going through your filmography, because each night we're on a little mini vacation, we've been watching a movie that you're in. Oh, my God. Okay. That's mortifying.
然后是我的第二件事，这让我的家人完全惊呆了。所以你出演了许多我家人最喜欢的电影。我所有的孩子都因为今天能见到你而感到非常高兴。但当我们浏览你的电影作品时，因为我们每天晚上都在进行一个小小的短假，我们一直在看你出演的电影。哦，天哪。好吧。那太丢人了。
No, no, it was great. It was great. But so as we're looking up your filmography, my husband was like, wait a second. We were in a Hallmark Christmas movie together. And I was like, what? Wait. First of all, my kids and I didn't even know my husband was in a Hallmark Christmas movie. It's called Farewell. Farewell, Mr. Cringle. Because that's the only Hallmark movie I did. Okay. Are you ready for this? He played your husband who died in the plane crash. Stop. Who I never met. No, you had no scenes together. Shot on another day, like a flashback. Yeah, yeah.
不，不，这很棒。这很棒。但当我们查找你的电影作品时，我丈夫说，等一下。我们一起演过一部 Hallmark 圣诞电影。我当时想，什么？等等。首先，我和我的孩子们甚至不知道我丈夫演过 Hallmark 圣诞电影。它叫《告别》。《告别，克林格先生》。因为那是我拍的唯一一部 Hallmark 电影。好吧。你准备好听这个了吗？他扮演了你死于空难的丈夫。停。我从未见过的人。不，你们没有对手戏。在另一天拍摄的，就像闪回一样。是的，是的。
They're all your flashbacks, but yes. No. Isn't that crazy? I have to track down how to watch that. That's an easy find or no? That's an easy find. And also, we found the scene where you drift off and thought and then you flash back to him talking to you.
那都是你的闪回，但是的。不。那不是很疯狂吗？我得去查查怎么看那部电影。那很容易找到吗？那很容易找到。而且，我们还找到了你陷入沉思然后闪回到他和你说话的场景。
And my kids are just maybe the same. is one of their new favorite things that we've ever discovered. Like, they can't get over it. It's, you know, I, by the way, that was one of the most fun jobs. Like doing a Hallmark movie, you know, it's like so dialed in and, you know, you shoot like in Santa Clarita or somewhere up there. Oh, I did a Hallmark Christmas movie. Was it two years ago? And it's still one of the most fun experiences I've had. Oh, my gosh. It was so great. Everybody's so nice. It was just like they treat you so well and it was so great. but I don't think I've seen it since it debuted. Well, you're very good in it.
我的孩子们可能也是一样。这是我们发现的他们最喜欢的新事物之一。就像，他们无法释怀。你知道，顺便说一句，那是我最有趣的工作之一。就像拍一部 Hallmark 电影，你知道，它非常专注，而且，你知道，你在圣克拉丽塔或那里的某个地方拍摄。哦，我拍过一部 Hallmark 圣诞电影。是两年前吗？它仍然是我经历过的最有趣的体验之一。哦，天哪。太棒了。每个人都那么好。他们对待你非常好，这太棒了。但我认为自从它首映以来我就没看过。好吧，你在里面演得很好。
Thank you. Okay, my last thing is you and I both graduated in the class of 1989. Well, hello. Hello. Hello. And I told my kids that. And then I told them, I guess this isn't so much a thing anymore. But like when we were in high school, every graduating class had their own chant.
谢谢。好吧，我的最后一件事是你和我都是 1989 届的毕业生。好吧，你好。你好。你好。我告诉了我的孩子们。然后我告诉他们，我想这已经不再是一回事了。但就像我们在高中时，每个毕业班都有自己的口号。
Do you remember? Like ours was, we're so great. We're so fun. the class of 89. And my kids are like, what? I wondered if that was a Texas thing because Angela asked me what my school chant was. And I thought, well, I don't remember having one necessarily. I don't either.
你还记得吗？就像我们的是，我们太棒了。我们太有趣了。89 届。我的孩子们说，什么？我怀疑那是不是德克萨斯州的特色，因为安吉拉问我我的学校口号是什么。我想，好吧，我不记得一定要有一个。我也不记得。
And I went to Catholic school in Pennsylvania. But the tune you just gave, and I wasn't a cheerleader in high school, but I just remember that same chant is, it's all right, it's okay. we're going to beat them anyway. Yes. So it's just whatever words. Exactly. I know.
我在宾夕法尼亚州上的天主教学校。但你刚才给出的曲调，虽然我高中时不是啦啦队长，但我记得同样的口号是，没关系，没问题。我们反正会打败他们。是的。所以不管是什么词。正是如此。我知道。
We thought we were so cool and we would chant that. Like at pep rallies, each grade would go and say their grade chant. And then there were like the party girls, like the kind of wild gals. And they extended it to we're so cool. We're so fine. We drink wine or something like that. We're the class of 89. Yeah.
我们以为我们很酷，我们会高喊那个。就像在动员大会上，每个年级都会去喊他们的年级口号。然后还有那些派对女孩，就像那种狂野的女孩。她们把它扩展为我们太酷了。我们太好了。我们喝葡萄酒之类的。我们是 89 届。是的。
But yeah. I feel like even in the way. world that I was in, which was very different than the John Hughes Breakfast Club world, that was so relatable because of all the clicks. You know, there were the jocks, but we didn't call them the sportos or the, you know, we didn't call them that. But the people that when you would bus in to the parking lot in the morning and you see the kids standing on the street corner smoking, like there were kids that smoked in
但是的。我觉得即使在我所处的世界里，那与约翰·休斯的《早餐俱乐部》世界非常不同，但因为所有的派系，它非常有共鸣。你知道，有运动员，但我们不叫他们“运动狂”或者，你知道，我们不那样叫他们。但当你早上坐大巴进入停车场，看到孩子们站在街角抽烟，就像高中里有抽烟的孩子。哦，是的。我不是其中之一。我们叫他们“瘾君子”。是的。仅仅因为他们抽香烟。哦，是的。哦，是的。
high school. Oh, yeah. I was not one of them. We called them the drugies. Yeah. Just for smoking their cigarettes. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
我的意思是，如果他们抽香烟，他们可能也吸毒，对吧？他们可能也抽了一点大麻。我敢打赌他们可能还喝过葡萄酒冷却器。那是一个如此简单的时代。确实。你的播客有什么令人愉快的地方，克里斯汀，我们必须大声说出来。哦，非常感谢。是的，那是我们所有人。
I mean, they probably did drugs if they smoked cigarettes, right? They probably smoked a little marijuana, too. And I bet they might have like had a wine cooler. It was such a simple time. It was. What is so enjoyable about your podcast, Christine, we have to shout it out. Oh, thank you so much. Yeah, that's something that we all.
三个人共同点。我们都是做播客的女士。你的播客叫《嘿，老兄，90 年代来电了》。你讨论 90 年代。我们讨论。现在，这是和你共同主持人大卫·拉沙尔一起，他也出演了尼克儿童频道的《嘿，老兄》。是这样吗？是的。《嘿，老兄》对你们的任何听众来说都是我从 1989 年开始出演的节目。那是我高中的最后一年，直到 91 年。它只是尼克儿童频道最早的剧本电视节目之一。那是早期的尼克儿童频道。不是现在《爱卡莉》的尼克儿童频道。它不浮华。它不酷。它就像他们真正尝试的新节目。所以我们做了那个节目几年。但它在 1991 年结束了。没有人有手机。没有人有电子邮件。就像我们都有从彼此那里收集的家庭电话号码和家庭住址。
three have in common. We're all ladies who podcast. Your podcast is called Hey Dude, the 90s called. And you discuss the 90s. We do. Now, this is with your co-host, David Lashar, who was also on Nickelodeon's Hey Dude. Is that right? Yes. Hey Dude for any of your listeners was a show that I was on from 1989. It was my senior year in high school to 91. And it was just sort of one of Nickelodeon's first scripted television shows. And it was the early Nickelodeon. It's not the Nickelodeon now of the Icarly. Like it wasn't flashy. It wasn't cool. It was like new programming that they were really trying out. So we did that show for a couple of years. But it ended in 1991. And nobody had cell phones. Nobody had email. Like we all had home phone numbers and home addresses that we had collected from each other.
并不是我们所有人都保持联系。我们很多人搬到了洛杉矶，在那里保持了一段时间的联系，但直到我们开始聚会，我们才真正重新联系上。我们为 20 周年聚会举办了一场活动，我们所有人都重新联系并加入了一个群聊。所以大卫·拉沙尔，
and not all of us stayed in touch. A lot of us had moved to L.A. and stayed in touch for a bit there, but it really wasn't until we started having reunions. And we did an event for the 20th reunion that we all reconnected and got on a group chat. And so David Lashar,
你知道，我们的小故事是我们在这个节目中约会过。我们在亚利桑那州图森拍摄。我们约会过。我们在节目结束前分手了。所以那有很多青少年的、焦虑的、约会、分手、心碎、戏剧性。我们仍然必须在拍摄现场一起工作。所以我们真的没有保持联系。很长一段时间。是他带着播客的想法来找我的。所以我真的很
you know, our little story is that we dated while we were on the show. We shot in Tucson, Arizona. We dated. We broke up before. the show ended. So it was a lot of teenage, angsty, dating, broke up, broken hearts, drama. And we still had to work together on location. So we really didn't stay in touch. A long time. And he's the one who came to me with the idea for the podcast. And so I was really
诚实。我说，我必须对你诚实。就像，我知道播客现在很流行，但我，甚至不知道该怎么做。他说，不，我们只是谈论我们的节目。我们谈论我们。因为《嘿，老兄》在那些年里找到了一点邪教追随者。所以如果你在那些年里处于某个年龄段，并且你有尼克儿童频道，人们开始在外面认出我们。是的。
honest. I said, I have to be honest with you. Like, I know podcasts are all the craze, but I am, would not even know how to go about it. And he's like, no, We would just talk about our show. We'd talk about us. Because Haydude sort of found this little cult following. So if you were a certain age during those years and you had Nickelodeon, people started recognizing us out in. Yes.
我们的制片人马特指着自己。而且，我们的音响工程师萨姆，今天没和我们在一起，让我们答应你，他也是《嘿，老兄》的超级粉丝。我爱你们。抱歉打断一下，但那是我。我出生于 84 年。那就像我的节目。这太有趣了，它是其中第一个
Our producer match is pointing to himself. But also, our sound engineer, Sam, who's not with us today, made us promise that we tell you that he was a huge fan of Haydud as well. I love you guys. I'm sorry to interrupt, but that was me. I was born in 84. That was just like my show. And that's so interesting that it was the first one of those
因为我没有任何背景，但那是那个和《向你的短裤致敬》。正是如此。全部投入。向你和整个团队致敬。它太好了，我仍然记得情节要点、角色。你们在幕后约会？是的。
because I didn't have any context, but it was that and salute your shorts. Exactly. All in. And just kudos to you and the entire crew. It was so well that I still remember the plot points, the characters. You guys were dating behind the scenes? Yeah.
是的。现在让你大吃一惊，对吧？很抱歉打断，只是想说，喜欢那个节目，喜欢主题曲。珍娜和安吉拉，你们知道主题曲吗？我不知道。我不知道这个节目。我看了它一点点。所以我现在知道这个节目了。
Yeah. Blowing your mind right now, right? So sorry to interrupt, just wanted to say, love that show, love the theme song. Jen and Angela, do you know the theme song? I don't. I don't know this show. I watched a little bit of it. So I now know the show.
但主题曲是什么？我有点想听听。它非常朗朗上口。一旦你唱出来，它就会在你的脑海里。克里斯汀，在期待这个的时候，我一直在家里唱它，我的孩子们说，你在做什么？这是什么歌？马特，请唱出来。
But what is the theme song? I kind of want to hear it. It's very catchy. Once you sing it, it's kind of in your head. Christine, in the anticipation of this, I've been singing it around my house and my kids are like, what are you doing? What is this song? Matt, please sing it.
现在听听。克里斯汀，你准备好了吗？五，六，七，八。它有点狂野，有点奇怪。当你在牧场安家时，开始你的马，跟上来。因为如果你坚持不住，你就不能骑马。
hear it now. Christine, are you ready? Yeah, sure. Five, six, seven, eight. It's a little wild and a little strange. When you make your home out on the range, start your horse and come along. Because you can't get a ride if you can't hold on.
唱歌。Yippie tie, aye. Yippie, guy, aye. 什么？就像牛仔说的那样。再说一遍。我不知道为什么我在唱这个。独唱。
Singing. Yippie tie, aye. Yippie, guy, aye. What? Like the cowboys say. Say it again. I don't know why I'm singing this. solo.
伙计们，这是在牧场吗？这就是为什么它叫这个名字吗？是的。它在一个牧场上。是的。在一个牧场上。明白了。我从主题曲里听出来了。
Guys, is this on a dude ranch? Is that why it's called? Yes. It's on a dude ranch. Yes. On a dude ranch. Got it. I'm getting it from the theme song.
你听出来了。看，我告诉过你整个故事，这是我见过马特·比格尔最活跃的一次。这对我来说是一个解锁的人生时刻。我喜欢那个节目。喜欢那首歌。它找到了它的小观众。我们就这么说吧。然后你们都长大了，开始认出我们并看到我们。
You're getting it. See, it told you the whole story and this is the most animated I've ever seen Matt Beagle. This was just a life moment unlocked for me. I love that show. Love that song. It found its little audience. Let's just put it that way. And then you all grew up and started to recognize us and see us.
然后人们来到我们面前说，让我们做个聚会。总之，长话短说，大卫来找我说，让我们做个播客。如果你愿意的话，我们谈论我们的节目，但也谈论 90 年代，这是我们真正开始职业生涯的十年。所以这太棒了。播客非常有趣。我们就像那个能行的小火车。我们有很多朋友来，我们重新联系，但我们也遇到
And then people came to us and said, let's do a reunion. And so anyway, long story short, David came to me and said, let's do a podcast. If you'd be into it where we talk about our show, but also just the 90s, which was the sort of the decade that we truly got our career started in. So it's been a blast. The podcast has been so much fun. We're like the little engine that could. We've got lots of friends who come on that we reconnect with, but then we meet a
很多我们从未认识但一直是粉丝的人。所以这太有趣了。我也理解你们，作为闺蜜做这件事，并且有那种指定的时间来抽出时间在一起聊天，你知道，带人进来谈论你们在节目中的共同经历。我只是喜欢它。我觉得这是一个很棒的平台。所以，是的，所以我喜欢做它。而且，是的，他叫 90 年代来电了。是的。好吧，克里斯汀，你之前提到你和我多次交集。最近在纽约市，我在《推销员之死》的后台看到了你，那太棒了。
a lot of people that we've never known, but have been fans of. So it's just been so much fun. And I get it for you, too, to be doing this as besties and to sort of have that time appointed to sort of carve out and be together and chat and, you know, bring people on and talk about your shared experience on the show. I just love it. I feel like it's such a great platform. And so, yeah, so I love doing it. And yeah, he'd do the 90s called. Yeah. Well, Christine, you mentioned earlier that you and I have crossed paths many times. And very recently in New York City, I saw you backstage at Death of a Salesman, which was amazing.
你总是那么令人愉快，那么美妙。你让我想起了我的闺蜜安吉拉，她从不认识陌生人。你就是那种人。我想我之前告诉过你，我不知道你来自《嘿，老兄》，但我是在你拍《布雷迪家族》电影时发现你的。你很快就成了我的喜剧灵感来源之一。我记得看到你在里面的表现，只是想，她是怎么做到的？
And you're just always so delightful and so wonderful. You remind me of my BFF, Angela, who's never met a stranger. You're just one of those people. And I think I've told you this before, but I did not know you from Hey, Dude, but I discovered you when you did the Brady Bunch movie. And you very quickly became one of my comedy inspirations. I remember seeing you in that and just thinking, how is she doing that?
她是怎么掌握那种令人难以置信的讽刺和喜剧时机的？然后我在拍《荣誉之刃》时偷了你的东西。你丈夫本·斯蒂勒是那部电影的制片人。我记得见到他。在片场告诉他我是你的超级粉丝，我正在偷你的东西。所以我需要知道你是如何处理玛莎·布雷迪这个角色的。你是如何塑造那个角色的？你创造了一个多么了不起的角色。
How is she nailing that incredible satire and comic timing? And then I stole from you when I did Blades of Glory. And your husband, Ben Stiller, was a producer on that movie. And I remember meeting him. and telling him on set that I was a huge fan of yours and that I was stealing from you. And so I need to know how you approached that role of Marsha Brady. How did you build that character? What a phenomenal character you created.
首先，谢谢你。那是最棒的。顺便说一句，珍娜，我记得《荣誉之刃》发生的时候，然后回家把那个故事告诉了我。我当时想，什么？那太神奇了。太酷了。所以谢谢你。听着，你知道，当我们谈论午餐盒时，对我来说现实是《布雷迪家族》是我放学后的享受。就像我只记得无论它在联合播出时是什么时间，你知道，我不记得在黄金时段和最初播出时看到它。但它每天都在播出，可能在 4:30 或 5 点左右。我只记得，有点。放学回家看《布雷迪家族》。就像我看到的每一集都倒背如流，从里到外。显然，当我得到这个角色时，我挖掘得更深。
First of all, thank you. That's like the greatest. And by the way, Jenna, I remember when Blades of Glory was happening and then came home and told me that story. And I was like, what? That's amazing. That's so cool. So thank you for that. Listen, you know, when we talked about the lunchboxes, like the reality for me was the Brady Bunch was my after school treat. Like I just remember whatever time it was on in syndication, you know, I don't remember seeing it when it was on in primetime and the original run. But it was on every single day, probably in like the 430 or 5 o'clock hour. And I just remember, kind of. coming home from school and watching the Brady Bench. Like every single episode I've seen backwards and forwards inside out. Obviously, when I got the part, I dug deeper.
但我挖掘得更深，甚至去试镜这个角色。但我太了解它了。成长过程中，我确实有那头长长的金发。我的意思是，我没有 70 年代的造型，但我会模仿她，因为我们太喜欢这个节目了。就像，我们对他们去夏威夷的剧集，那个小提基，还有孩子们互相吓唬的剧集，阁楼里的假鬼，着迷。就像，有些剧集我会记得放学回家，你打开它
But I dug deeper even to audition for the part. But I knew it so well. And growing up, like, I did have that long blonde hair. I mean, I didn't have a 70s look, but I would just kind of do impressions of her because we loved the show so much. Like, we were obsessed with the episodes of when they'd go to Hawaii and the, little tiki and the, and then the episodes of the kids scaring each other and the fake ghost in the attic. Like, there were episodes that I would remember coming home from school and you turn it on
在前两分钟就知道，哦，是大峡谷那一集。那是三部曲。我开始在我们的 VHS 录像带上录制它们。我收藏了《布雷迪家族》的 VHS 录像带。当这个角色出现时，并不是说我来自一个喜剧家庭，就像本来自一个喜剧家庭一样。嗯。因为我的家人，宾夕法尼亚州阿伦敦，不在演艺圈，对演艺圈一无所知，但我热爱戏剧。我从我很小的时候就开始做戏剧，你知道，就像，我会做所有的
and in the first two minutes know, oh, it's the Grand Canyon episode. It's the three-parter. And I started recording them on our VHS tapes. And I had this collection of VHS tapes of the Brady bunch. When the part came along, it's not like I come from a comedy family the way Ben comes from a comedy family. Mm-hmm. Because my family, Allentown, Pennsylvania, not in show business, knew nothing about show business, but I love theater. And I started doing theater from the time I was just, you know, like, I would do all
学校戏剧，我喜欢它。但我的家人很有趣。就像，我爸爸只是个有趣的人。他总是有一个有趣的、讽刺的笑话。我们只是懂了。我们懂幽默，成长过程中看了很多喜剧。所以我对电影的记忆，我们去录像带店租的经典电影，比如《条纹》和《疯狂高尔夫》，就像，你知道，我们真的很喜欢的经典喜剧。
the school plays and I loved it. But my family was funny. Like, my dad was just a funny guy. He always just had a funny, sarcastic joke. We just got it. We got humor and we watched a lot of comedies growing up. So my memory of movies, the classic movies that we'd go to the video store to rent, like, stripes and caddyshack and like, you know, just like classic comedies that we just really enjoyed.
《嘿，老兄》是一部情景喜剧，设定在一个牧场上。那是一个多机位节目，但它在户外。所以我学到了一点在镜头前表演的东西。但《布雷迪家族》的试镜，我想我搬到洛杉矶时拍了两部小电影。然后他们正在选角替换。我不知道你们是否记得。芝加哥有一个巡演叫《真实生活布雷迪家族》，是一群素描喜剧演员。安迪·里希特在里面，还有简·林奇。他们在 90 年代初在洛杉矶做了这个。我在洛杉矶看到了。好的。所以。我在洛杉矶看到了。那是一个现场讽刺的、
And Hey Dude was a sitcom, like a situation comedy set on a dude ranch. It was a multi-camera show, but it was outdoors. So I got to learn a little bit of sort of acting it on camera. But the Brady Bunch audition, I think I had done two little movies when I'm moved to L.A. And then they were casting a replacement. I don't know if you guys remember. There was a tour that started in Chicago called The Real Live Brady Bunch, which was a bunch of sketch comedy actors. Andy Richter was in the bunch and Jane Lynch. And they did this in L.A. In the early 90s. I saw it in L.A. Okay. So. I saw it in L.A. It was like a live satirical,
喜剧性的《布雷迪家族》。正是如此。他们每周都会做一集，他们会像游戏
comedic Brady Bunch. Exactly. They would do an episode every week and they'd have like a game
节目元素一样，他们让它在 70 年代变得非常时髦，它就变成了一个
show element beforehand and they made it really groovy in 70s and it just became like
很酷的节目，他们正在替换玛莎一个月，因为她得到了
a cool thing to go see and they were replacing the Marsha for like a month because she had gotten
一个试播集之类的。所以当时我的室友读到了它，其中一个你知道
a pilot or something. So my roommate at the time read about it and one of those you know
后台西部的细分。是的，正是如此。正是如此。她只是说，你知道，
breakdown backstage West. Yes, exactly. Exactly. And she just said, you know,
你应该去参加。就像，你应该去试镜，因为你太迷布雷迪了。就像，这并不奇怪。就像，我生命中的每个人都知道我喜欢《布雷迪家族》。所以我问了我的经纪人，我去试镜了，我真的觉得他们几乎是当场就雇用了我。等等，你在电影之前就在现场表演了？是的，但只有大约四周。但关于《真实生活布雷迪家族》的事情是他们都年纪大了。我加入时是小组里最年轻的一个。他们是成年人在扮演角色。对。对。扮演青少年。是的。所以我最年轻，我记得当我结束它时，
you should go in on this. Like, you should get an audition for this because you're so Brady obsessed. Like, it was no surprise. Like, everyone in my life knew that I loved the Brady Bunch. So I asked my agents about it and I went in an auditioned and I really feel like it was almost like they hired me on the spot. Wait, you were in the live show before the movie? Yes, but only for like four weeks. But the thing about the real live Brady Bunch was they were all older. I was the youngest one in the group when I came in. They were adults doing the characters. Right. Right. Playing teenagers. Yeah. So I was the youngest and I remember when I wrapped it up,
那个团队，你知道，他们只是说，你知道，有一个布雷迪电影，我们听说正在开发中，我们和它没有任何关系。但你应该把它放在你的雷达上，因为你的年龄正合适。所以我什么也没说。然后有一天突然，我的意思是突然在 1990 年，无论哪一年，92 或 93 年，我的答录机上收到了舍伍德·施瓦茨打来的电话，只是冷不丁地给我打电话，说，我想和你见面，因为他们是电影的制片人，但他们并不真的想要他们的创意投入。但他就像，我想和你见面。我去了舍伍德·施瓦茨的家，和他谈论了《布雷迪家族》。舍伍德·施瓦茨是《布雷迪家族》和《吉利根岛》的创作者。总之，你当时是不是像捏，捏自己？是的。这就是那个有《布雷迪家族》午餐盒的孩子。是的。哦，天哪。我看到的只有舍伍德·施瓦茨的名字。所以是的，这是一个捏我的时刻，我至今不敢相信我竟然没有保留答录机上的小磁带。但谁知道呢？所以我必须问你，克里斯汀，当你经历电影试镜过程时，你内心的感觉是什么？你自信吗？你当时想，这是我的吗？因为我会分享，当我为《办公室》试镜帕姆时，我当时想，我就是帕姆。我是帕姆。我感觉到了。关于我的一切都知道我是帕姆。我对大多数试镜没有那种感觉。大多数试镜，我想，好吧，听着，我可以做得很好，但别人可能也行。但对于帕姆，我觉得骨子里有一种对这个角色的所有权。我觉得这就是我成为演员的原因。我会做很多其他
the team that, you know, they just said, you know, there is a like, Brady movie that we heard is in development and we have nothing to do with it. But you should just get that on your radar because you'd be the perfect age for it. So I didn't say anything. And then out of the blue one day, I mean out of the blue on my answering machine in 19. 90, whatever year this was, 92 or 93, I got a message from Sherwood Schwartz calling me, just cold calling me, saying, I'd love to meet with you because they were producers on the movie, but they did not really want their creative input. But he was like, I'd love to meet with you. I went Sherwood Schwartz's house and got to talk to him about the Brady Bunch. Sherwood Schwartz is the creator
事情，我肯定，但这就是我最初进入这个行业的原因。所以我只是好奇，当你试镜这个角色时，你内心在哪里？好吧，你做到了，但我内心知道，没有人能比我做得更好。是的。无论他们是否看到了这一点，你知道，顺便说一句，这不是我立即见到导演和制片人。我见到的是选角导演黛博拉·奎拉。是的。走进派拉蒙地块，走进去。她太积极了。
of the Brady Bunch and Gilligan's Island. Anyway, were you just like pinch, Pinching yourself? Yes. This is the kid that had the Brady Bunch lunchbox. Yes. Oh my gosh. And all I would see was Sherwood Chords his name at the, you know. So yes, it was a pinch me moment that I cannot believe to this day that I still didn't keep my little tape from the answering machine. But who knew? So I have to ask you, Christine, as you're going through the process of auditioning for the movie, what was your like internal feeling? Were you confident? Were you like, this is mine? Because I'll just share that when I was auditioning for Pam for the office, I was like, I am Pam. I'm Pam. I feel it. Everything about me knows that I'm Pam. And I don't feel that way about most auditions. Most auditions, I think, well, listen, I could do a great job, but probably so could someone else. But for Pam, I felt like deep in my bones and ownership of this character. I felt like this is why I became an actor. I'll do many other
我记得，我感觉很好，因为我太自信了。我的意思是，这是我一生都在做的事情。我只是觉得，你知道，你克服了试镜的紧张。但我真的觉得如果我没得到这份工作，那么我不知道这是否是我应该从事的行业。是的。就像这是为我而生的。做这件事是为了我。
things, I'm sure, but this is why I got in this business in the first place. And so I'm just curious, where were you internally as you're auditioning for this role? Well, you nailed it, but I knew it in my core that there was nobody who could do it better than me. Yeah. And whether or not they saw that, You know, and this was, by the way, it wasn't like I immediately was meeting with a director and producers. I was meeting with Deborah Quilla, the casting director. Yeah. And walking on the paramount lot and walking in. And she was so positive.
所以我的试镜，黛布立即带我回去见贝蒂和制片人。我很确定我见到了他们。基本上就是这样。他们没告诉我我得到了它，但我再也不用回去单独试镜了。下一轮是把我与不同的简和不同的辛迪配对。所以我认为这就像三次进入，感觉就像，显然，当你开始看到我是唯一被配对的人时，你也会开始感到更自信。这就是重点。当你确信他们爱你时。我只记得贝蒂，她甚至不是布雷迪家族的。显然她一直在研究它，但她并不像了解布雷迪的一切。所以我带来的东西，我不认为他们甚至知道是玛莎主义或玛莎。或莫琳·麦考密克的她方式。顺便说一句，我一直说，当我谈论它时，
I remember, I felt great because I was so confident. I mean, it's what I'd been doing my whole life. I just felt like, you know, you get through the nerves of the audition. But I really felt like if I don't get this job, then I don't know that this is the business. I should be in. Yes. Like this was made for me. This doing this was for me.
对我来说，以一种不嘲笑的方式做这件事非常重要。因为我太喜欢它了。我没有看那些节目。是的，我没有看那些节目说，这太荒谬了。这太有趣了，这就是我将如何模仿这个。但就像，我太喜欢它了。我希望它非常纯粹，非常真实。
So my audition, Deb brought me back immediately for Betty and the producers. And I'm fairly sure that I met with them. And that was pretty much it. They didn't tell me I got it, but I never had to go back in an audition solo again. The next rounds were matching me with different jans and different Cindy's. And so I think it was like sort of all in going in three times and feeling like, obviously, when you start seeing that I'm the only one being matched, you start to feel more confident too. That's the thing. When you know they love you. And I just remember Betty, who was not even a Brady bunch. Obviously she had been studying it, but it wasn't like she knew everything Brady. So I was bringing things that I don't think they even knew were Marciaisms or Marcia. or Marine McCormick's way of how she. And by the way, and I say it all the time when I talk about it,
非常莫琳。所以这就是我处理它的方式。然后我一直这么说，因为在我们的播客上，它太 90 年代了，而且在行业里是一个非常不同的时代，我得到的一件事，我不是一个超级重的人，但他们让我减掉 10 磅。什么？你是认真的吗？你太娇小了。是的。我这么说是因为我一直，我不像你那么娇小。安吉拉，但我像，我不是一个大块头，但他们，你知道，他们想让我减掉 10 磅，但这没关系。我当时想，我会减掉 10 磅。就像我，当然，当那个要求来到我面前时，我很尴尬，因为，顺便说一句，今天永远不会发生。而且，它只是像，我不是当时唯一被要求为角色减肥的人。那只是事情
it was so important for me to do it in a way that was not making fun. Because I loved it so much. I didn't look at the shows. Yeah, I didn't look at the shows and say, this is ridiculous. This is so funny. This is how I'm going to parody this. But it was like, I love it so much. I want it to be so pure and so genuine.
如何进行。但我当时想，我会做的。然后那个笑话是电影的过程中，如果你仔细看，我开始把 10 磅加回去，你可以看到它。就像我会看起来圆一点进入一个场景，然后像我看起来瘦一点离开场景，仅仅是因为他们必须重拍事情。但没有，在电影的过程中，我真的开始款待自己。无脂冷冻酸奶是当时的大狂热，那是我的款待。我当时想，哦，我拍完了。我要去见我的室友，我们要去大冷冻酸奶店，买一个上面有大量糖针的冷冻酸奶。你讲那个故事太有趣了，克里斯汀，因为我拍过一部电影
and so Maureen. And so that was really how I approached it. And then I say this all the time because on our podcast, which is so 90s, and it was a very different time in the industry, the one thing that I got, and I was not a super heavy person, but they asked me to lose 10 pounds. What? Are you serious? You're so petite. Yes. And I say it because I've been, I'm not petite like you. Angela, but I'm like, I was not a big person, but they, you know, they wanted me to lose 10 pounds, but it didn't matter. I was like, I'll lose 10 pounds. Like I'll, of course, I was embarrassed when that ask came my way because, by the way, it would never happen today. And also, it just was like, I wasn't the only person ever being asked to lose weight for a roll back then. That was just how
叫《永不止步》。他们没让我减肥，但他们给我找了一个教练和一个营养师。我吃的是那种盒装餐。从来没有明确说过。是的。但这绝对是我有史以来最瘦的时候。在那部电影里，我有大约 90 套服装更换。我的一件服装是一套高级定制骑马装。我必须穿着一套与约翰·C·赖利相配的手工串珠高级定制骑马装骑马。前一天晚上，或者也许前几个晚上，我在酒店房间里熬夜。克里斯·帕内尔在电影里，我们点了客房服务的芝士汉堡。我当时想，我他妈的不能吃这个煮鸡肉和任何东西。就像，当时甚至连羽衣甘蓝都没有。
things went. But I was like, I'll do it. And then the judge. joke is over the course of the movie, which if you watch it very closely, I start to put the 10 pounds back on and you can see it. Like I'll come into a scene looking a little rounder and then like I exit the scene looking a little thinner just because of how they had to reshoot things. But no, over the course of the movie, I really started to treat myself. Non-fat frozen yogurt was the big craze at the time and that was my treat. I was like, oh, I wrapped. I'm going to meet my roommate, we're going to go to the big chill and get a frozen yogurt with a huge thing of sprinkles on the side. It's so funny you tell that story, Christine, because I was in a movie
事情的经过。但我当时想，我会做的。然后法官。笑话是在电影拍摄过程中，如果你仔细看的话，我开始把那10磅肉长回来，你可以看出来。比如我进入一个场景时看起来圆润一点，然后离开场景时看起来又瘦了一点，这只是因为他们必须重拍一些镜头。但不是，在电影拍摄过程中，我真的开始犒劳自己了。脱脂冷冻酸奶是当时的一大风潮，那就是我的奖励。我当时想，哦，我杀青了。我要去见我的室友，我们要去Big Chill买一份冷冻酸奶，旁边还要加一大份糖针。克里斯汀，你讲这个故事太有趣了，因为我当时在拍一部电影
called Walk Hard. And they didn't ask me to lose weight, but they got me a trainer and a dietitian. And I was on like these box meals. It was never explicitly said. Yeah. But it was definitely the tiniest I ever was. And in that movie, I had something like 90 wardrobe changes. And one of my pieces of wardrobe was this couture riding outfit. I had to ride a horse in like a hand-beated couture riding outfit that matched John C. Riley. And the night before, or maybe a couple nights before, I had stayed up late in my hotel room. Chris Parnell was in the movie, and we ordered room service cheeseburgers. I was like, I can't fucking eat this boiled chicken and whatever. Like, it wasn't even kale back then.
叫《永不止步》。他们没有要求我减肥，但他们给我找了教练和营养师。我当时吃的是那种盒装餐。从来没有明确说过。是的。但这绝对是我有史以来最瘦的时候。在那部电影里，我有大约90套服装更换。我的一件服装是这套高级定制骑马装。我必须穿着一套手工缝制的高级定制骑马装骑马，这套衣服和约翰·C·赖利的很搭。在前一天晚上，或者可能是前几天晚上，我在酒店房间里熬夜。克里斯·帕内尔也参演了那部电影，我们点了客房服务的芝士汉堡。我当时想，我他妈才不吃这煮鸡肉什么的。那时候甚至还没有羽衣甘蓝呢。
It was like this other sort of like weird boiled green on the side. I was like, I'm going to lose my mind. And so we got cheeseburgers and a shake and we watched a movie just, hanging out and then I went in the next morning to put on the riding outfit. I swear, it was like the next morning and it didn't fit. The riding outfit. The couture hand-beated, made-for-meed, riding outfit. Panic. Panic and suit. What do you mean like it? No. It was, it wouldn't buckle. Like overnight. Like overnight. My body was like, oh, I love this, right? Yes. Your body was so. So. For this cheeseburger, that it was like, we're keeping this cheeseburger forever.
那就像是旁边放着某种奇怪的煮熟的绿色蔬菜。我当时想，我要疯了。于是我们买了芝士汉堡和奶昔，看了一部电影，只是闲逛，然后第二天早上我去穿那套骑马装。我发誓，那是第二天早上，它穿不上了。那套骑马装。那套高级定制、手工串珠、为我量身定做的骑马装。恐慌。恐慌和诉讼。你是什么意思，像它？不。它就是，它扣不上了。就像一夜之间。就像一夜之间。我的身体好像在说，哦，我喜欢这个，对吧？是的。你的身体太。太。为了这个芝士汉堡，它就像是，我们要永远留着这个芝士汉堡。
Right. We're keeping it immediately. Yes. And yeah. How do you cheat that? Like if it doesn't buckle and it's couture and a bodice. You know what they, no. I couldn't get it on.
对。我们立刻留着它。是的。还有，是的。你怎么作弊呢？如果它扣不上，而且是高级定制的紧身胸衣。你知道他们，不。我穿不上它。
At the last minute, they got like, just like a standard black riding outfit that they, like, did their best to embellish in three hours. It did not match. We did not have matching writing outfits. in the movie. But that was a crazy time. That's the only time that ever happened to me on a movie. And you know, you hear stories all the time of people changing their appearance for a movie role. Like they get muscles or they gain weight. But for me, with this, I left that experience thinking, wow, that was a scrutiny I did not enjoy and is not something that I wanted to
在最后一刻，他们找了一套标准的黑色骑马装，他们尽力在三个小时内进行了装饰。它不匹配。我们在电影里没有配套的骑马装。但那是一段疯狂的时光。那是我在电影中唯一一次发生这种情况。你知道，你经常听到人们为电影角色改变外貌的故事。比如他们练出肌肉或增加体重。但对我来说，经历了这件事，我离开时心想，哇，那是一种我不喜欢的审视，也不是我想要在未来重复的事情。
repeat in the future. Right. And luckily, when it was all over, I just kind of went back to eating and living the way I had before. But it could have, you know, it's hard, especially if you're younger, I think. And that's the thing. By the way, I was 23 years old, right, when I did it. So that's the time you're actually really coming into like a woman's body at that time, right? You know, it's not like that. And I just remember, I was so confident in what I was doing.
对。幸运的是，当一切结束后，我只是回到了以前的饮食和生活方式。但它可能，你知道，这很难，尤其是如果你更年轻的话，我想。就是这样。顺便说一句，我做这件事的时候才23岁，对吧？所以那是你真正开始拥有女性身体的时候，对吧？你知道，不是那样的。我只记得，我对自己在做的事情非常有信心。
So I never worried that the job was in jeopardy. So I always felt very confident in that role. And going back to it, the way I knew it was mine, yes. Like, I knew it was mine. And the fact that the way the universe aligned and they saw that, that's always the thing. You just hope that they see it. But they get what you know inside. And it's the greatest gift that keeps on giving. Like, I just love it. I never tire of a Brady Bunch conversation. I never tire. And I recently met Maureen. I met Maureen very briefly. at the premiere of the sequel, I think. A lot of them did cameos in the first movie. She didn't do a cameo in it, but she came to the premiere. So I met her briefly. But very recently, we got to connect doing a Zoom reading for something. And we hung out and had lunch.
所以我从不担心这份工作会受到威胁。所以我对那个角色一直感到非常有信心。回过头来看，我知道它是我的方式，是的。就像，我知道它是我的。事实上，宇宙以某种方式排列，他们看到了这一点，这总是关键。你只是希望他们能看到。但他们得到了你内心所知道的东西。这是不断给予的最伟大的礼物。就像，我只是喜欢它。我永远不会厌倦关于《布雷迪家族》的谈话。我永远不会厌倦。我最近见到了莫琳。我在续集的首映式上非常简短地见到了莫琳，我想。他们中的很多人在第一部电影中客串了。她没有在里面客串，但她来了首映式。所以我简短地见到了她。但最近，我们通过Zoom阅读剧本联系上了。我们一起出去吃了午饭。
And, like, it was just her birthday. Like, we text. She sends me recipes. Like, the greatest one way. Wait, were you in a restaurant together? Like, the two of you having lunch? Were people losing their minds? No.
而且，就像，刚好是她的生日。就像，我们发短信。她给我发食谱。就像，最棒的单向。等等，你们是在餐厅里吗？就像，你们两个在吃午饭？人们有没有疯掉？没有。
We were in the valley, in the waitress that, you know, our server who was probably like 21. Like, no idea. We took selfies. Nobody knew, which was so great. Like, we just had this sacred space to just get to know each other and so many similarities. And by the way, the greatest gift to me is that I'm not on Twitter, but I remember Ben over the years would say, like, Maureen McCormick just wrote something really nice about you on Twitter, about you playing the part. And I was like, oh my God, like that's the greatest thing ever that I got her stamp of approval.
我们在山谷里，那个服务员，你知道，我们的服务员可能才21岁。就像，完全不知道。我们拍了自拍。没人知道，这太棒了。就像，我们只是有这个神圣的空间来互相了解，而且有很多相似之处。顺便说一句，对我来说最伟大的礼物是我不在Twitter上，但我记得本多年来会说，比如，莫琳·麦考密克刚刚在Twitter上写了一些关于你的非常好的话，关于你扮演那个角色。我就想，哦天哪，这真是最棒的事情，我得到了她的认可。
Like, that's all I ever wanted was for her to know that I was doing it with so much love. Like, you know, she was a California girl. So she had very specific way. I was a Pennsylvania girl. So her sort of California dialect is very specific to her. And so I needed to hear it. I needed to do it. I needed to honor it.
就像，我一直想要的只是让她知道我是带着如此多的爱在做这件事。就像，你知道，她是加州女孩。所以她有非常独特的方式。我是宾夕法尼亚女孩。所以她的那种加州方言对她来说非常独特。所以我需要听到它。我需要做到它。我需要尊重它。
And so yeah, it's my greatest joy. That's amazing. And you know, it lives on and on. Obviously, you know that. I mean, my daughter showed me a TikTok reel. I am not on TikTok, you know, because I don't want to embarrass my kids. But she showed me. And it's like, it's you.
所以是的，这是我最大的快乐。那太棒了。而且你知道，它一直延续下去。显然，你知道这一点。我的意思是，我女儿给我看了TikTok视频。我不在TikTok上，你知道，因为我不想让我的孩子们尴尬。但她给我看了。就像，那是你。
And it's like something like 10 times when Marcia was iconic or something like that. And it's all these clips. They're fantastic. Yeah. My daughter told me the same thing. She's like, the Brady Bunch is like having a moment, right? how on like with the Shore Jan meme and some of those Bradyisms. But I think it's great.
就像有10次玛西娅成为标志性人物之类的。全是这些片段。它们太棒了。是的。我女儿也跟我说了同样的话。她说，《布雷迪家族》就像正在经历一个时刻，对吧？比如Shore Jan的表情包和一些布雷迪式的用语。但我认为这很棒。
I love it. I love that it lives on and that I got the stamp of approval. Like mission accomplished. Should we also chat with you about some of the office questions you had for us? Well, I just want to say that my office experience, and I know Ben has talked about this before, because the joke in our house was that we were huge. fans of the original, the British series. Like, we felt like that was like about as perfect a show that you could possibly make.
我喜欢它。我喜欢它延续下去，而且我得到了认可。就像任务完成。我们要不要也和你聊聊你对我们提出的一些关于办公室的问题？嗯，我只是想说，我的办公室经历，我知道本以前谈过这个，因为我们家里的笑话是我们是原版英国系列的忠实粉丝。就像，我们觉得那几乎是你能制作出的最完美的节目。
Like, it was just, we loved it, you know, it was so sacred in our house. And Ben, as a production company, remembers getting the potential. He was like, oh, they're going to be doing an American office. And it came to his company. And Ben was like, there's no way you can touch that. There's no way you can touch that material successfully. Like there's no version. And I think in his mind, too, he was like, there's no version where I can see myself figuring out how to do that because that's so unique.
就像，我们只是，我们爱它，你知道，它在我们家里是如此神圣。本作为一家制作公司，记得得到了这个潜力。他当时想，哦，他们要拍美国版的《办公室》。它来到了他的公司。本当时想，你不可能触碰那个。你不可能成功地触碰那个素材。就像没有版本。我想在他心里，他也想，我看不到自己能弄清楚如何做到这一点，因为它是如此独特。
It's so specific. So for Ben, it was like, no, that's not for us, which he's still to this day is like, clearly I can't see things. Listen, that show was a hot potato that was just passed around. Like, people, it landed. They're like, would you consider? And they tossed it as quick as they could for all the reasons you're saying. Right. And for whatever reason, Greg Daniels was like, I'll meet with them.
它是如此具体。所以对本来说，就像，不，那不适合我们，直到今天他还是说，显然我看不见东西。听着，那个节目是一个被传来传去的烫手山芋。就像，人们，它落地了。他们说，你会考虑吗？他们尽可能快地把它扔掉了，原因正如你所说。对。不管出于什么原因，格雷格·丹尼尔斯说，我会和他们见面。
Okay. But not at first. You know, that he was really going back and forth about it. See, that's so interesting. Because I think Ben always says, like, Greg obviously had this, like, he knew. He knew. He saw it. you know, you, so I'll be so honest, like, we were late to even watching it because it was like,
好的。但起初不是。你知道，他真的在反复考虑这件事。看，这太有趣了。因为我觉得本总是说，格雷格显然有这个，就像，他知道。他知道。他看到了。你知道，你，所以我说实话，就像，我们甚至看得很晚，因为它就像，
yeah, when did you discover it? Was it on streaming or was it even when it was on live? It was on streaming. It was on streaming. And also, the other thing, too, for me, I was always, like, even my TV taste as a consumer, you know, in the early 2000, I was like 24. I'll stop my life to watch 24. I loved 24. I will stop everything. I'm obsessed with Jack Bauer. I would say 24 arrested development. I had a couple shows that I was like all in.
是的，你什么时候发现它的？是在流媒体上还是在直播时？是在流媒体上。是在流媒体上。而且，另一件事，对我来说，我总是，就像，即使是我作为消费者的电视品味，你知道，在2000年初，我才24岁。我会停止我的生活去观看《24小时》。我喜欢《24小时》。我会停止一切。我迷上了杰克·鲍尔。我会说《24小时》、《发展受阻》。我有几部节目是我全身心投入的。
And then you got to be on arrested development. Sally, by the hell. That was Sally Sitwell. By the way, that was I think one of those perks where I, when I saw that show, I reached out to my agents and I was like, I will do anything on that show. Like anything on that show. And so that was one of those nice things where it was like, oh, they're offering you a little arc as this character.
然后你参加了《发展受阻》。莎莉，见鬼。那是莎莉·西特韦尔。顺便说一句，我想那是那些福利之一，当我看到那个节目时，我联系了我的经纪人，我说，我愿意在那个节目里做任何事。就像那个节目里的任何事。所以那是那些好事之一，就像，哦，他们提供给你一个小弧线作为这个角色。
So cool. Not knowing it would have a couple different reboots and that character would live on in weird ways. But so for the, for us with the office, it was. And by the way, I had worked with John and Ken Quappas on License to Wed. Oh my God, Christine, I'm in that movie. I know. I know. I can't believe I didn't bring that.
太酷了。不知道它会有几个不同的重启，那个角色会以奇怪的方式延续下去。但对我们来说，关于《办公室》，它是。顺便说一句，我和约翰和肯·夸帕斯在《结婚证书》中合作过。哦天哪，克里斯汀，我在那部电影里。我知道。我知道。我不敢相信我没有提到那个。
up on there are three things in common. I thought that was going to be one of them, but then we got sidetracked on because yours were so good. But yeah, there were, you know, a bunch of you guys popped up in it. And so, and I was like, oh my God, they're all so funny. They're so good. So it was like in my ether of like to Ben, I was like, we got to just watch. Like, we have to start watching the office. And as anybody who has a husband or partner where you always say you're going to watch it and wait for with the other person to watch it. Like it'll, it never happens. It's always like you never started.
上面有三件事是共同的。我以为那会是其中之一，但后来我们因为你的太好了而偏离了轨道。但是的，有，你知道，你们中的一群人出现在里面。所以我当时想，哦天哪，他们都太搞笑了。他们太棒了。所以它就像在我的以太里，就像对本，我说，我们必须看。就像，我们必须开始看《办公室》。正如任何有丈夫或伴侣的人，你总是说你要看它，并等待和另一个人一起看。就像它永远不会发生。总是像你从未开始过。
It takes everybody's lives, get busy. So our daughter, in her teen years, she started watching it. Well, started out as her thing with Ben and they would watch together. And it was just like one more, one more. And then I fed into it. And then I had to go back and rewatch season one to start to get caught up. And I just feel like for someone who came to it late, it is such a joy to have a show and the way the show went for it and the way it worked.
它占据了每个人的生活，变得忙碌。所以我们的女儿，在她十几岁的时候，她开始看了。嗯，开始是她和本的事情，他们会一起看。就像再看一集，再看一集。然后我也加入了。然后我不得不回去重看第一季来开始赶上。我只是觉得对于一个看得很晚的人来说，拥有一部节目以及节目发展的方向和它的运作方式是一种快乐。
And I think it's just like it transcends time. Like I feel like the thing about the office for you guys is it's so timeless the show. Other than jokes that you know would not be shot today from some of the earlier seasons. Like I went back and started in the, I think it's the beginning of season five, the weight loss episode. Speaking of weight loss. Speaking of weight loss. Right. Yes. Yes. Oh my gosh. What business would throw a weight loss contest today, nobody. And make all their employees stand on a scale. Dying. And Dwight literally driving Phyllis to a bad neighborhood to make her walk back because he feels like Phyllis is the one who's like secretly
而且我认为它就像超越了时间。就像我觉得《办公室》对你们来说是如此永恒的节目。除了你知道今天不会拍摄的早期季节的一些笑话。就像我回去开始看，我想是第五季开始，减肥那一集。说到减肥。说到减肥。对。是的。是的。哦天哪。今天有什么企业会举办减肥比赛，没人。并让所有员工站在秤上。笑死。还有德怀特真的开车把菲利斯带到一个糟糕的社区，让她走回来，因为他觉得菲利斯是那个偷偷
binging the food. And gaining weight. So it just is. like the gift that keeps on giving in a show that I feel like it gave us the gift of being able to watch it together as a family and just belly laugh, but also, you know, weep at, you know, your stuff, Jenna, with John, like the, you know, Pan, like those moments of like him getting on his knee and proposing to you at the gas station and the pouring rain when you guys have met halfway. So I just kept watching. I was like, I'm just going to keep watching it. This is going to be my summer binge again.
暴饮暴食的人。而且体重增加。所以它就是。就像不断给予的礼物，在一个节目中，我觉得它给了我们能够作为家庭一起观看并开怀大笑的礼物，但也，你知道，为你流泪，你知道，你的东西，珍娜，和约翰，就像，你知道，帕姆，那些时刻，比如他跪下在加油站向你求婚，以及当你们在中途相遇时倾盆大雨。所以我只是继续看。我当时想，我只是要继续看它。这将再次成为我的夏季狂欢。
Like, I'm just going to keep going. Okay. I love that. Do you have a favorite character? Is there like a character you're always like that? That's it for me. Well, what I wanted to ask you, Angela, too, is like, and all of you guys. And I know you're all playing characters.
就像，我只是要继续。好的。我喜欢那个。你有最喜欢的角色吗？有没有像你总是觉得那样的角色？对我来说就是那样。嗯，我想问你的是，安吉拉，还有，你们所有人。我知道你们都在扮演角色。
But did you feel like the writers and collectively, as they got to know you guys in the early stages, started to write towards things they knew specifically about you or about things that you liked. Like, did they play into that in an exaggerated way? Well, sometimes you would be having a conversation on set and then something you said would end up somehow in an episode. You know, you'd be like, oh, my gosh, the writers are on set with us because so many of them are also characters on the show. But no, my real life personality is nothing like my Angela Martin personality. Your rigidity.
但是你是否觉得编剧们和集体，当他们开始在早期阶段了解你们时，开始写向他们特别了解的关于你们的事情，或者关于你们喜欢的事情。就像，他们是否以夸张的方式利用了这一点？嗯，有时你们会在片场交谈，然后你说的一些话会以某种方式出现在剧集中。你知道，你会想，哦，天哪，编剧们和我们在一起，因为他们中的很多人也是节目中的角色。但不，我的现实生活个性一点也不像我的安吉拉·马丁个性。你的僵化。
Yeah, yeah. So that didn't often. In fact, sometimes they had to change words because I'm Southern and I couldn't say them. So like, you know, everyone that we work with here on the podcast knows I have a very hard time with vowels in front of L's, you know. So like I famously, like had this moment where I tell Andy that I want to, in the script, in the script it said hand tealed field. Hand, what? Hand tilled field. Hand tilled field. Did I say it? No. Hand-tealed field. Oh my God. See? Okay, so we did 14 takes and they're like, just forget it. Say hand plowed. You're just, you're not getting it.
是的，是的。所以那并不经常。事实上，有时他们不得不改变词汇，因为我是南方人，我不能说它们。所以就像，你知道，我们在这里播客中一起工作的每个人都知道我在L前面的元音有很大的困难，你知道。所以就像我著名地，就像有这个时刻，我告诉安迪我想要，在剧本里，在剧本里写着手工耕作的田地。手工，什么？手工耕作的田地。手工耕作的田地。我说了吗？没有。手工耕作的田地。哦天哪。看？好的，所以我们拍了14次，他们说，算了。说手工犁过的。你只是，你没弄对。
And so I think they would try to help me find her, you know? Yeah. But yeah, I think some of our things would end up in scripts that we would sort of be chatting about. Like Jenna and I both worked in corporate America, temping when we started our acting careers. And, you know, there was a man in the parking lot one time. I worked at 1-800 Dennis as an operator, and this guy got in and he flashed a few people, and I told the story, and that ended up in a script that Sillus gets flashed in the parking lot. And Jenna and I talked about these ridiculous, like, human resource meetings we'd have to go to.
所以我认为他们会试图帮助我找到她，你知道？但是的，我认为我们的一些事情会出现在我们聊天的剧本中。就像珍娜和我都在企业美国工作过，当我们开始演艺生涯时做临时工。而且，你知道，有一次停车场里有个男人。我在1-800 Dennis做接线员，这个家伙进来了，他向几个人闪露，我讲了这个故事，那最终出现在剧本里，菲利斯在停车场被闪露了。珍娜和我谈论了这些荒谬的，比如我们必须参加的人力资源会议。
And some of that made it into some episodes. But Jenna, what about you? Well, I feel like character-wise, there is an aspect of me that they moved into Pam, which is a little bit of sass and a little bit of snark. So when you see her take on Ryan, I think that is my personality that got written into Pam's personality. Because I think where Pam started, I'm not sure you'd ever see her do that. But my personality, I am like a speak up for yourself kind of gal.
其中一些进入了一些剧集。但珍娜，你呢？嗯，我觉得在角色方面，我有一个方面被他们移到了帕姆身上，那就是一点点傲慢和一点点讽刺。所以当你看到她对付瑞安时，我认为那是被写进帕姆个性的我的个性。因为我认为帕姆开始的地方，我不确定你会看到她那样做。但我的个性，我是一个为自己说话的人。
and I'm not a suffer in silence gal. And so I think they gave Pam a little bit of me in her way that she sasses at Ryan. Well, that's so funny that you said that because when you're talking about favorite characters, because everyone is so beloved. Like, it's so hard to pick, but there's so many great storyline. Like, obviously, Jim and Pam is like the iconic, but I just also feel like Angela and Dwight. it's like so wrong yet so right. And there's so much, there's so much satisfaction with you two together. Like it's so meant to be. I saw an article one time that said people would describe Jim and
而且我不是一个默默忍受的人。所以我认为他们给了帕姆一点点我的方式，她对瑞安傲慢。嗯，你说得太有趣了，因为当你谈论最喜欢的角色时，因为每个人都如此受人喜爱。就像，很难选择，但有这么多伟大的故事情节。就像，显然，吉姆和帕姆是标志性的，但我只是也觉得安吉拉和德怀特。这太错了但又太对了。而且你们两个在一起有太多的满足感。就像它是命中注定的。我曾经看到一篇文章说人们会描述吉姆和
Pam. They'd say, aw. But if they had to describe Dwight and Angela, they'd say, ew. Exactly. I was like, okay. It's so cute. Like, it's so oddly. It's so oddly. Like happy making of, you know, I don't know why. I don't know why it's so satisfying. But then when you go into like, Ryan is the worst. The worst. But also I love, on our rewatch doing this podcast, he became my favorite character. I was like, I love this character so much.
帕姆。他们会说，啊。但如果他们必须描述德怀特和安吉拉，他们会说，呃。完全正确。我当时想，好的。这太可爱了。就像，它太奇怪了。它太奇怪了。就像让人快乐，你知道，我不知道为什么。我不知道为什么它如此令人满足。但当你进入比如，瑞安是最糟糕的。最糟糕的。但我也喜欢，在我们重看这个播客时，他成了我最喜欢的角色。我当时想，我太喜欢这个角色了。
And then when Pam sassed him finally in the later seasons, I was like, this is my favorite thing. It's so good. When they do their whole Michael Scott paper company. and she has to, like, sit at that little table with him. Exactly. Amazing. I was just going to say, like, when he sort of comes back, tail between his legs, and he's in, like, the temp mode, but he's also still just being such an ass.
然后当帕姆在后来的季节终于对他傲慢时，我当时想，这是我最喜欢的事情。这太好了。当他们做他们整个迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司时。而她不得不，比如，和他坐在那张小桌子旁。完全正确。太棒了。我正要说，比如，当他那种回来，夹着尾巴，他处于，比如，临时工模式，但他同时也只是表现得像个混蛋。
Like, he's just... Such an ass. He's just still thinks he's got this power. And it's just... PJ's so funny, too. I mean, just the way he plays it. But I love that big stand-up moment, too, where Jim is, like, I need to show them because no one has respect for Jim in that sort of management position, right?
就像，他只是……真是个混蛋。他只是仍然认为他拥有这种权力。而且它只是……PJ也太搞笑了。我的意思是，他扮演它的方式。但我喜欢那个大的站立时刻，也是，当吉姆是，比如，我需要向他们展示，因为没有人尊重吉姆在那种管理职位上，对吧？
So, and I really love the moment when Ryan gets sort of demoted into the little like room, the closet. Yes, the closet is so great. It's so good. Which, funny enough, was partly because they really needed him in the writer's room. And when his character moved into the main bullpen, it was like kind of a problem. Because he was in the background of everything. So they're like, how do we get him? come out of here again and their idea was, oh, this would be a great plot point that he has to work in that closet.
所以，我真的很喜欢瑞安被降职到那个小房间，壁橱里的时刻。是的，壁橱太棒了。这太好了。这，有趣的是，部分原因是因为他们真的需要在编剧室里有他。当他的角色搬进主办公室时，就像是个问题。因为他在所有事情的背景里。所以他们说，我们怎么能让他？再次从这里出来，他们的想法是，哦，这将是一个伟大的情节点，他必须在那个壁橱里工作。
It's so good. That's just what I love. It's like it's for us in the house, what it's on. I don't know what night it was. And obviously they just keep going if you don't hit exit out. Right. And I saw like my family start to like fill in around me. Oh.
这太好了。这就是我所喜欢的。就像它对我们家来说，它是什么时候播出的。我不知道是哪天晚上。显然如果你不点击退出，他们就会一直播放。对。我看到比如我的家人开始像填补我周围一样。哦。
And it's just so great because new generations are seeing it for the first time and falling in love with it again. And there's not lots of shows anymore where it's like the whole family can watch, you know? Like there's shows where you as parents can sit in on a show your kid likes, but this is to me, I mean, obviously kids of a certain age, and my kids are adult, you know, children now. But it's just been like a joy for us. And I just think you guys are amazing. Like in everything else that you've done too, like you're both such good actors who just need to just keep doing it because comedic geniuses as well. And I'm such fan. Christine, this has been so lovely. And I'd like to say, okay, Angela's husband has played your
而且这太棒了，因为新一代第一次看到它并再次爱上它。而且不再有很多节目是像全家都可以看的，你知道？就像有些节目作为父母你可以坐在孩子喜欢的节目里，但这对我来说，我的意思是，显然是特定年龄的孩子，而我的孩子现在是成年人了。但这对我来说一直是一种快乐。而且我只是觉得你们太棒了。就像你们做的其他所有事情一样，你们都是如此优秀的演员，只需要继续做下去，因为你们也是喜剧天才。而且我是如此粉丝。克里斯汀，这太可爱了。我想说，好的，安吉拉的丈夫扮演了你的
husband in a movie. I have played your husband's wife in a movie. But what is missing is some combo of you, me, and Angela playing, I don't know. Definitely you and Angela could play sisters in a movie. maybe I can be your crazy friend or neighbor. I don't know, but somehow I think the three of us need to be in a movie together. I think so too. You can be our cousin. I'll be our cousin, Jenna. And like we're manifesting it.
丈夫在电影里。我扮演了你丈夫的妻子在电影里。但缺少的是你、我和安吉拉扮演的某种组合，我不知道。绝对是你和安吉拉可以在电影里扮演姐妹。也许我可以做你们疯狂的朋友或邻居。我不知道，但不知何故，我认为我们三个需要一起拍一部电影。我也这么认为。你可以做我们的表亲。我做我们的表亲，珍娜。就像我们在显化它。
Let's manifest. Let's do it. We're putting it out loud. We're saying it out loud. I think we have to find each other in a, like, something really fun to work on together. But clearly the universe is bumping us into each other, right? It is. Totally.
让我们显化。让我们做吧。我们正在大声说出来。我们在大声说出来。我认为我们必须在某种，比如，真正有趣的事情中找到彼此一起工作。但显然宇宙正在把我们撞在一起，对吧？是的。完全。
We're getting close. We just have to solidify it now. Yes, we will. And I also need for the three of us to like have ladies lunch in person. I need an in person hang. I'm putting it out there. 100%. I'm in. Great.
我们快要接近了。我们现在只需要巩固它。是的，我们会。而且我也需要我们三个像亲自进行女士午餐。我需要一个亲自聚会。我把它放出来。100%。我加入。太棒了。
I love this. Well, that's perfect. Until our lunch when we meet again, Christine, thank you so much for spending time on office ladies. This was the best. Thank you guys so much. Lady, I'm going to say it again. We need to be her best friend.
我喜欢这个。嗯，那太完美了。直到我们再次见面吃午饭，克里斯汀，非常感谢你在办公室女士上花时间。这是最好的。非常感谢你们。女士，我要再说一遍。我们需要成为她最好的朋友。
Yeah. Also, just putting it out there. Could she be another mom detective? Oh, lady. I know. Do we need to do a movie called mom detective with Christine? You know, I was wishing that we could have done this interview all in studio together. But honestly, I think if she had been here in person, I don't know if we would have ever let her leave.
是的。另外，只是把它放出来。她能成为另一个妈妈侦探吗？哦，女士。我知道。我们需要拍一部叫《妈妈侦探》的电影和克里斯汀一起吗？你知道，我一直希望我们能一起在工作室里完成这次采访。但老实说，我想如果她亲自来到这里，我不知道我们是否会让她离开。
it might have been good she was on Zoom. Well, you know, we're already on a text thread. We have been texting. It's true. Listen, everyone, thank you so much for listening. Please check out Christine on her podcast. Hey, dude, the 90s called. You know, Malora Hardin was her guest.
她能在Zoom上可能很好。嗯，你知道，我们已经在短信线程上了。我们一直在发短信。这是真的。听着，大家，非常感谢你们的收听。请在她的播客上查看克里斯汀。嘿，伙计，90年代打来了。你知道，马洛拉·哈丁是她的嘉宾。
And there might be two other gals guesting on that. Two office ladies might pop on by. In the near future. All right, you guys. Thank you, Christine, for just giving us so much of your time. You were so gracious. And thank you all for listening. We'll see you next week.
而且可能有另外两个女孩在那个节目上做客。两个办公室女士可能会在不久的将来出现。好了，你们。谢谢你，克里斯汀，给了我们这么多时间。你太亲切了。谢谢你们大家的收听。我们下周见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听办公室女士。办公室女士是Odyssey的呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔，我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。办公室女士由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。